[Music]
all hail Queen demi lovato the 27 year
old delivered a perfect rendition of the
national anthem ahead of Super Bowl 54
on Sunday
literally nailing every single high note
[Music]
[Applause]
Demi's sounded like an angel and she
looked like one too
taking the field in an all-white Sergio
Hudson suit and to Cory Jules with her
long black locks down and curled fans
immediately took to social media
completely losing it over her
performance Khloe Kardashian tweeted
quote okay Demi you better sang hashtag
Superbowl they was beautiful and Hoda
Kotb wrote yes hashtag Demi Lovato that
was perfect
ads are you Ryan Seacrest also tweeted
his support writing crushed it
Demi was all smiles as she entered the
stadium ahead of her powerhouse
performance one of her first since
stepping out of the spotlight in 2018
and she was on cloud nine when et's
Kevin Frazier caught up with her just
moments after leaving the field is it
true ten years ago you tweeted this is
what you wanted right here's the 2010
tweet she's referring to quote one day
I'm gonna sing the national anthem at a
Super Bowl one day well she made that
dream come true on Sunday and every
moment of it was perfect